think about the amazing diversity of
living things on earth ranging from
single-celled organisms like bacteria to
complex multicellular organisms like
ferns moths birds and humans even among
a given family or single species there
are widely varying features like color
and size
would it surprise you to learn that all
these different groups of organisms are
thought to have Arisen from a single
common ancestor
how exactly did the stunning diversity
of Life stem from one organism
the answer is evolution
Evolution refers to the change in a
population that is inherited over
Generations
to understand that we can start with the
depiction of the tree of life also
called the phylogenetic tree which is a
way to visualize how different species
of organisms are evolutionarily related
the tree of life was constructed based
on evidence from fossils the genetic
makeup of different organisms and a wide
range of scientific experiments
on the tree stemming from the common
ancestor different lines represent the
organisms and nodes show where two or
more groups diverge from each other
forming multiple distinct species
a species refers to a group of organisms
that can interbreed with each other
Evolution that happens at the population
level meaning within an individual
species is referred to as microevolution
in contrast macroevolution is used to
describe Evolution at or above the
individual species level let's zoom in
to talk about microevolution
every population contains inherent
variation and there are multiple factors
that can influence how frequently a
given variant is found in that
population
these factors include migration also
known as gene flow natural selection
mutation and genetic drift and they
drive microevolution within a population
let's use the example of how Evolution
shaped the finches on the Galapagos
Islands which was studied by Charles
Darwin back in the mid-1800s
single population of finches that
originally landed on the islands and
started Living and breeding there
imagine then a fraction of those birds
flew over to different nearby Island
this migration event led to different
frequencies of certain genes on the
different Islands which can then persist
if the birds on each island breed with
each other
another way Evolution can come about is
natural selection the finches on
different Islands had different beak
sizes and shapes in addition the islands
on the Galapagos have different types of
food sources for the birds seeds leaves
and insects birds with one size and
shape of beak were best able to eat
certain foods so those birds survived
best on islands that had that type of
food available
this is referred to as having a fitness
advantage over time the finches with the
beak shape better for eating the
corresponding food source bred with each
other and Nest pest on that trait on
through the generations a clear example
of evolution
another factor that influences the
process of evolution is mutation which
refers to changes in the DNA sequence of
genes that encode for different traits
if a mutation occurs that results in a
new trait and that trait is advantageous
to the organism it will generally
provide a fitness advantage therefore
that trait is more likely to be passed
on to subsequent Generations
if the trait is detrimental to the
survival or breeding of an individual
within a species it is unlikely to be
passed on for example a mutation that
led to a brilliant red pigment on the
birds might be disadvantageous because
it would make those finches more visible
to predators
and lastly Evolution can occur through
random genetic drift which refers to
change in frequency of a gene variant in
the population over time by chance
meaning that genetic drift does not take
into account whether the gene variant is
advantageous or disadvantageous
while these examples we've talked about
so far refer to random events driving
Evolution there are examples of how
human behavior can drive microevolution
for example in response to pesticide use
some insects have developed resistance
to those chemicals allowing them to
survive when exposed to those pesticides
as you've seen Evolution occurs from one
generation to the next and is influenced
by multiple factors migration natural
selection mutation and genetic drift
studying Evolution allows us to
understand the history of life on earth
and the remarkable diversity that comes
with it as well as providing a framework
for thinking about evolution in future
Generations
[Music]